The humble bumble bee has a surprisingly flexible
brain.
They can come up with most efficient solution
to receive a reward, rather than simply mimicking what they see others do.
The bees were taught to move a ball to the middle of a platform.
If successful, they got a sugary treat.
They were taught by other bees,
by fake bees held by scientists,
or by an invisible “ghost bee”--actually a magnet
But they didn’t learn so well from the ghost
bees. Real bees were better teachers
Rather than mimicking the conditions they were shown, bees went off script to solve problems
The demonstrations they learned from all involved
yellow balls.
This ball is black, not yellow
But the bee still chooses it as the closest
ball to the center.
It knows it doesn’t need a yellow ball specifically;
any ball will do
This kind of cognitive flexibility is previously
unknown in insects--clever girls!